s
ne voulaient pas d'eux
à leurs côtés.
Stépha- Les excuses arrivent 10s
après la formation de ce
bataillon d'hommes noirs
déterminés à servir pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale,
et le racisme.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Je suis ici aujourd'hui
afin d'offrir les excuses
pour la façon horrible dont
ces patriotes ont été traités.
- À l'époque, l'armée canadienne
des Noirs.
- Presque tous les volontaires
venant des communautés noires
se sont vus refusede servir leu.
- Environ 600 hommes
d'ascendance africaine
qui provenait du Canada,illes
étaient déterminés à surmonter
le racisme pour contribuer
à l'effort du Canada pendant
En 1916, le deuxième bataillon
en Nouvelle-Écosse.
C'était la première unité
à rassembler des mais elle étain
refusait de l'envoyer combat
en raison des préjugés racistes
de l'époque. Les recrues étaien,
en Nouvelle-Écosse, et aussi
à Windsor, en Ontario,
avant leur départ pour l'Europe
servi aux côtés du Corps
forestier canadien dans le Jura,
en France, et à r
le front en bois et à effectuer
d'autres tâches de soutien
comme la construct
et l'entretien de voies ferrées.
Le bataillon a été dissous
en 1921.
À leur retour au Canada,
ces hommes n'ont pas été reçus
les honneurs qu'ils méritaient,
souligne le député fédéral
Greg Fergus.
un siècle plus tard.
Les dignitaires se sont adressés
aux parents et aux descendants
ARTHUR J. LEBLANC, lieutenant-
gouverneur de la Nouvelle-Écosse
- J'exprime ma profonde
servi le deuxième bataillon
de construction. Je reconnais
également les épreuves qu'ont
leurs descendants.
- Le Centre culturel noir
de la Nouvelle-Écosse a remercié
ses excuses.
phanie Blanchet,
Radio-Canada, Halifax.